[Aplausos]
[Música]
nueva guinea es uno de esos lugares que
parece de otro planeta podría estar en
la tierra media de tolkien y en ese caso
sería por solo lugares así podemos
encontrar noticias como esta en pleno
siglo 21
[Música]
explorador desaparecido descubierto en
papúa nueva guinea a estas alturas del
seguro que estaréis pensando señor de
los anillos' isla del pacífico
fonseca no te estarás equivocando de
isla weiss no ya sé que el señor de los
anillos' se rodó en nueva zelanda pero
lo que nadie sabe es que fue nueva
zelanda por que peter jackson no se
atrevió con papúa bueno y ni él ni nadie
con dos dedos de frente
papúa-nueva guinea mujeres y niños
asesinados en masacre tribal y os
preguntaréis por qué os hablamos de
nueva guinea en visual político y
problema político pueden tener por estos
lares pues creedme hay mucho que contar
de entrada fijaos en este mapa
como podéis ver nueva guinea es una isla
de hecho es la tercera isla más grande
del mundo sólo por detrás de australia y
groenlandia pero hay algo más si os dais
cuenta hay una frontera una frontera
trazada con escuadra y cartabón esta
frontera separa papúa nueva guinea que
es un país independiente de la papúa
occidental que es una región de
indonesia pues bien resulta que en papúa
occidental hay un enorme movimiento
independentista y diréis pues muy bien y
a nosotros que nos importa porque sobre
importarnos que los papúa no se quieran
separar de los indonesios pues por esto
[Música]
la mina de oro de freeport en papúa es
la más grande del mundo exacto hablamos
de oro y muchos otros recursos entre
otros gas natural y petróleo vamos que
papúa es un morador en toda regla tienen
hasta su propio monte del destino donde
se pueden forjar anillos y lo que haga
falta y todo esto explica por qué el
nacionalismo papúa no es un problema
político de primer orden así que la
pregunta es si quieren exactamente los
papúes es porque quieren independizarse
de indonesia y hasta qué punto pueden
conseguirlo hoy vamos a responder a
todas estas preguntas pero antes antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
ah
dos provincias y un estado durante años
nueva guinea estaba controlada por reino
unido a alemania y países bajos y digo
estaba controlada porque realmente nunca
fue una colonia como lo solemos entender
cada una de estas tres potencias se
limitaron a colocar una bandera y un
puerto para controlar el comercio
marítimo pero a casi nadie le importaba
lo que ocurría en el interior de la isla
así que las cosas en nueva línea no
cambiaron demasiado ni antes ni después
de que llegaran los europeos y todo esto
explica que tampoco hubiera grandes
conflictos durante la descolonización
básicamente en los años 60 y 70 todas
las potencias occidentales abandonaron
la isla sin rechistar
básicamente dividieron la isla en dos
partes con una frontera que es el
meridiano 141 la parte oriental pasó a
ser papúa-nueva guinea un país
independiente y la parte occidental pasó
a ser una provincia indonesia y os
preguntaréis y qué hacían las tribus
papúes mientras tanto pues digamos que
su vida no ha cambiado prácticamente
nada los dan y son una de las etnias más
populosas de los papúes sin contacto con
el hombre blanco hasta principios del
siglo 20 vivían en la edad de piedra en
el momento de su descubrimiento
los europeos no comprendieron la
importancia de las tribus danny hasta
que un avión sobrevoló la isla en 1938 y
descubrió el gran valle danny se cree
que son más de 200.000 los aborígenes
solamente de esta etnia un 5% de la
población de la papúa indonesia pero
esperado un momento porque si pensabais
que a estas alturas la civilización ya
ha llegado a papúa estáis muy
equivocados las tribus siguen con sus
costumbres de siempre
[Música]
una tribu remota en nueva guinea corta
la piel de los niños con cuchillas para
que parezcan cocodrilos y si habéis oído
bien he dicho las tribus porque en esta
isla conviven más de 1000 tribus cada
una con su idioma y sus costumbres y
probablemente haya muchas más que ni
siquiera conocemos y diréis y porqué
indonesia se quedó con la parte
occidental pues muy fácil porque
indonesia era una colonia de países
bajos así que cuando se independizaron
reclamaron este trozo de nueva guinea
que había pertenecido a países bajos
también como parte de su territorio y
como ninguna de estas tribus hizo un
llamamiento decidieron dársela al nuevo
estado indonesio el problema es que en
el momento en el cual el dictador
suharto padre de la parte indonesia puso
un pie en la isla se dio cuenta de que
había mucho más que tribus a día de hoy
un tercio del gas que exporta indonesia
se produce en papúa y luego tenemos la
mina grasberg
wow todos los dias freeport produce 240
kilos de oro en papúa pero esperad un
momento porque no es oro todo lo que
reluce
también tienen plata y cobre de hecho es
la segunda mina de cobre más grande del
mundo tras la llamada mina escondida de
chile y claro cuando una isla te ofrece
tanto a cambio de tampoco lo que menos
te apetece es darles la independencia de
hecho el actual presidente de interés ya
joe y dado apuesta más bien por todo lo
contrario
[Música]
indonesia arrebata el control de la mina
grasberg de freeport terminando una
larga batalla lo malo de todo esto es
que el interés de indonesia por papúa se
limita a explotar sus recursos los
papúes son considerados ciudadanos de
segunda y el resto de ciudadanos de
indonesia los ve como inferiores hay un
racismo preocupante y los derechos
humanos son pisoteados en esta zona del
mundo muchos japoneses que son la etnia
predominante en indonesia se refieren a
los papúes como literalmente los monos y
eso como os podéis imaginar a los papúes
pues no les hace la más mínima gracia
los papúes convierten el insulto de mono
en un símbolo revolucionario la verdad
es que desde que yo con cuidado llego a
la presidencia el gobierno de yakarta ha
intentado cambiar las cosas están
construyendo autopistas y sacando leyes
más favorables a los indígenas pero esto
no es suficiente para los
independentistas de papúa y os
preguntaréis pero que quieren
exactamente los para cubanos indonesios
tal vez quieren unirse a sus hermanos
del este pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
fábula mala y para peor y nueva guinea
es morderla papu independiente es no se
el barrio más peligroso de mordor en
este caso es que como te pillo una tribu
te comen pero literalmente
pareja secuestrada y torturada por
caníbales en sus vacaciones de ensueño
en papúa nueva guinea ha esperado un
momento porque las ciudades son mucho
peores port moresby la capital de papúa
nueva guinea es considerada como la
ciudad más peligrosa del mundo de hecho
es territorio ras con los rasgos son
pandillas callejeras que campan a sus
anchas por la ciudad el alcohol las
drogas y los asesinatos son sus
pasatiempos preferidos y seguro que
estaréis pensando bueno a ver fonseca no
crees que estás exagerando un poquito
pues para nada mirad lo que pasó durante
la apec que es el foro de cooperación
económica asia-pacífico que quiso
celebrar su cumbre del año pasado en
port moresby
papúa nueva guinea acoge la cumbre de la
apec en un crucero ya lo habéis visto
por muchos cuerpos de seguridad y
guardaespaldas que pusieran los
políticos dijeron que no se emitían ahí
ni en broma así que tuvieron que
celebrar la cumbre en un barco atracado
en las costas de port moresby y como os
podéis imaginar las tasas de pobreza
extrema en papúa nueva guinea son la
sobrina liana alcanzan el 40 por ciento
en la parte indonesia hablaríamos del 25
por ciento y en el resto de indonesia la
tasa de pobreza es del 6% por supuesto
que estas estadísticas hay que
tomárselas con muchos factores
correctores porque como os digo hay
muchísimas zonas donde a duras penas se
sabe quién vive y cómo
[Música]
en cualquier caso los paganos indonesios
no quieren que indonesia les robe el gas
el oro y el cobre pero tampoco quieren
que se lo roben sus vecinos del este
ellos lo que quieren es ser un país
independiente en igualdad que es el
líder de los independentistas está
exiliado en londres su objetivo es
gobernar algún día lo que llamarían la
república de papúa occidental y la
pregunta es podrían realmente
independizarse veréis por el momento el
movimiento unido por la liberación de
papúa occidental que es lo que dirige
veni wenda ha reunido 18 millones de
firmas para solicitar a la onu que
organice un referéndum de
autodeterminación
ahora vamos a suponer que pudieran hacer
de verdad ese referéndum que pasaría
pues vamos a hacer un pequeño rebobinado
[Música]
el sistema no que decíamos que nadie
protestó cuando papúa occidental pasó a
manos de indonesia en realidad no es del
todo cierto como decíamos antes lo que
ahora es papúa indonesia fue en su día
una colonia entre comillas de países
bajos
tras la segunda guerra mundial indonesia
se independizó y nueva guinea quedó un
poco en el aire por un lado indonesia
quería incorporarla a su nuevo país pero
por el otro los neerlandeses decían que
no tenían ningún sentido pensadlo bien
hay más de 3.500 kilómetros de distancia
entre yakarta y papúa no hay ninguna
relación ni cultural ni histórica ni
económica entre el pueblo de iglesia y
el pueblo de nueva línea así que para
resolver esta disputa dijeron decidan
los papúa nos vamos a hacer un
referéndum el problema los que con más
de 1000 tribus cada una con su propio
idioma a hablar de democracia es como
hablar de conexión a internet de alta
velocidad así que el referéndum de 1969
conocido como el acta de libre elección
fue una auténtica farsa
se supone que podrían votar 800000
papúes sin embargo solo lo hicieron a
mano alzada 1000 personas seleccionadas
por el ejército de indonesia
las tropas hicieron su trabajo y los
papúes occidentales solamente pudieron
elegir una opción por unanimidad la
decisión adoptada fue seguir con
indonesia vaya sorpresa pero ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando por aquel momento
indonesia era una dictadura obviamente
no puedes esperar que un dictador
organice un referéndum limpio sin
embargo ahora las cosas han cambiado los
indonesios ya pueden votar en elecciones
libres en cualquier caso el problema
sigue siendo el mismo como haces
elecciones en un país tan tribal y aquí
es cuando entra en escena el sistema no
en una de estas lenguas papuanas
significa bolsa básicamente en los jefes
de las tribus van al colegio electoral
con una bolsa y dicen esto es lo que han
votado los míos en algunos casos ni
siquiera hay bolsa directamente le
preguntan al jefe de la tribu y dicen a
ver jefe del atributo quién vas a votar
pues yo voy a votar al partido x te voy
a votar al partido x muy bien jefe de la
tribu vamos a ver cuánta gente en tu
tribu que sí
o más o menos unas trescientas personas
persona arriba persona bajo y 35 cabras
porque es que nosotros a las cabras las
contamos como personas sabe sabe usted
muy bien muy bien pues 335 votos para el
partido x muchas gracias señor jefe de
la tribu ahora que tenga un buen día
como os podéis imaginar con este sistema
también organizado no nos extraña que el
actual presidente de indonesia yo con
cuidado se impusiera en papúa en las
últimas elecciones logrando tener más
votos que votantes
[Música]
la junta electoral de papúa descubre más
de un millón de votantes duplicados en
el censo para las elecciones de 2019
ahora imagina de este sistema aplicado
para un referéndum de autodeterminación
sería muy sencillo para los
independentistas para pues falsear los
datos y reivindicar que todos los papúes
quieren la independencia tampoco podemos
olvidar que también podrían votar todos
los javaneses que han emigrado papúa y
que hoy en día son aproximadamente un
tercio de la población concretamente el
tercio que es más fácil de medir en un
censo en otras palabras que dependiendo
de quien convoque el referéndum
cualquiera podría falsear lo
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros pues de papúa occidental salir
de la pobreza y convertirse en un estado
independiente creéis que necesitan
superar el tribalismo o es mejor
dejarles que sigan viviendo a su manera
y por último os gustaría enviar a peter
jackson a papúa-nueva guinea después de
la trilogía de 'el hobbit' podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que nadie al botón de
suscribirse darle a la campanita para
que os llegue una notificación al móvil
cada vez que publicamos un vídeo donde
si no os vais a enterar de lo que ocurre
en papúa nueva guinea y me vais a decir
que no es un historia fascinante pues
eso todos a suscribirse a visual
político dadle a la campanita y susan
gustado este vídeo darle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto